[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Over
the past few years
there's been a worldwide
focus on STEM education,
and nowhere is
that more apparent
than in the schools,
Build A Plane
challenge, where school
kids come together
to literally build an
airplane from scratch.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But first let me talk about this
airplane that's being built.
It's not a toy or a model.
It's not a drone flown
by remote control.
It's an actual, legitimate,
real-life airplane-- propeller,
instruments, seating for two.
This one here is a
work in progress,
built by these kids
that will one day fly
at one of the biggest
air shows in the world,
right alongside some of the most
impressive, most recognizable
aircraft.
But the satisfaction
of seeing the plane
you built fly in
front of thousands
isn't the reason
these kids do it.
I talked to Stuart Blakemore
who is in charge of STEM
at Wolverhampton
Academy, and who
is managing this
particular plane project,
and he expressed just how
powerful this program is.
STUART BLAKEMORE: The fact that
they are doing something real.
The fact that there's
something tangible.
And the fact that it is
hard and complicated,
it lifts the whole tenor
of what we're doing.
We've got a lot of
Boeing subcontractors
around where we are, and
we take the kids around
and work with them.
And when they see
the parts being made,
and they can identify it
with bits on the airplane,
it's difficult to
express verbally
the way that they are
operating at a level
that 11, 12, 13-year-old kids
should not be operating at.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, I
mean I imagine that it
can be life changing for sure.
STUART BLAKEMORE: Now, I know
that this project has probably
changed the lives-- really,
really dramatically changed
the lives of 15 to 20
people in our area.
INTERVIEWER: That change
comes through new skill
sets, knowledge, friends,
and opportunities.
Graduates of the program
administered jointly
by the Royal Aeronautical
Society and Boeing,
received scholarships,
apprenticeships, and jobs,
thanks to the
experience of building
an airplane with classmates
and a team of volunteers
who mentor and coach them.
I talked to one graduate
of the program who
echoed these sentiments.
What do you look back on
during the Build A Plane
with like the most fondness?
JOHN PHILLIPS: Well,
when I look back on it,
I see the way I've changed, and
the way I have helped people
change.
So, the way it changes them
and gets them into engineering.
So they could leave
and get an instant job
within an engineering facility.
INTERVIEWER:
Engineering that e word
kept coming up when I was
talking to people involved
in the project.
This is a major success and
a goal in STEM education--
to get kids excited about
science, technology, math,
and engineering.
What was your favorite thing
about It-- about building
the plane in general?
SUBJECT 1: That's really
hard because I've enjoyed
building most of the plane.
INTERVIEWER: So there's no one
thing, you just like all of it.
Are you going to take that
skill and go on and do
something else with it?
SUBJECT 1: Definitely
INTERVIEWER: Like what?
SUBJECT 1: I want to be an
engineer when I'm older.
SUBJECT 2: I want to be a
naval engineer when I'm older,
so this will help, definitely.
RAVI RAM GE: When I grow up, I
want to be a website designer,
but I'm also having a bit of
a, like a, change of plan,
thinking because this has
changed things for me.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
RAVI RAM GE: Yeah,
because now I'm
getting better in
Physics because,
before I never used to
know a thing about physics.
But now, I do, it's great.
INTERVIEWER: Now,
I don't know where
these kids were before they
started on their journey
to build an airplane.
I don't know what
their aspirations were
or what they wanted out of life.
But what I do know is
where they are now.
They are optimistic
and confident.
They are looking
towards a future
where they'll be putting to
use the skills they've learned,
not just hands on skills like
riveting and using power tools,
but how to work in teams,
how to use math in real life
situations, and how to see
a project through from start
to finish.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The plane these kids are
building isn't ready for flight
just yet, but I
was with them when
they got to see a past Build A
Plane success story take off.
And yes, they were
excited to see it fly.
But you can tell
they also couldn't
wait to get back to
their school to complete
their plane so in two years
they can be right back here,
watching a volunteer fly their
achievement overhead in front
of thousands.
Of course, that will
come with mixed feelings.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SUBJECT 3: So you know we built
it, and him to be flying in it.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
SUBJECT 3: You've got to be
terrified at the same time.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: In order
to respect the power
and ingenuity of
modern day aircraft,
you have to look to the past.
Meet Tracey Curtis-Taylor,
a true seeker
and aviator who restored
and flew a classic Boeing
Stearman around the world.
TRACEY CURTIS-TAYLOR: Everybody
calls this real flying.
So I'm going to take an airplane
like this around the world,
flying the rivers, the lakes,
THE shorelines at low level.
This is probably the best
flying adventure in the world.
INTERVIEWER: Thank
you for watching.
And make sure to
subscribe for more videos.